Speaker 1: After proudly announcing that
the state of Florida would investigate COVID
vaccine wrongdoing, recently reelected Republican
Governor Ron DeSantis went. Of course, to Fox News
on Fox News. He was interviewed by
laura ingraham and he is now going
full anti-vaxx. I believe this has
to do with a potential republican
presidential primary run against Donald
Trump. I will explain that to you in a
moment. But here is Ron DeSantis going full
anti-vaxx with laura ingraham last night.
Speaker 2: Learn today and hearing again
these voices, many of them suppressed
or people ostracized over the last few years.
Speaker 4: Well, Laura, like anything, I mean,
you take an arm and a shot and the weight of view.
Speaker 1: And the NRA, MRA,
that doesn't sound quite right.
Speaker 4: It is. Okay. What are
the benefits and what are the drawbacks? Yes, it
seems like our medical establishment never wanted
to be honest with people about the potential
drawbacks. And so you showed a clip from Dr.
Oladipo down here in Florida and the analysis
that he's done with people, particularly young
men who've taken the M RNA shots. We, of course.
Speaker 1: Had remember that that analysis was not
an actual Florida Department of Health letterhead.
It was completely unsigned. Ladipo published it
and it was based on cherry picked out of context,
inaccurate information. I can't read debunk that
quote. It's not even a study. It's a paper. I
don't even know what to call it that opinion
piece. I can't redo all of that right
now, but we have a dedicated segment
about that. It was not. It was bogus.
Speaker 4: Witnesses talk about their
experience and how were we in a situation. Yes,
Florida, we banned vaccine passports almost two
years ago. We banned the shot mandates for jobs
and saved a lot of people's jobs. Nevertheless,
throughout our country, you still have hundreds
of universities in other states that are still
mandating these boosters on these college kids
when any type of cost benefit analysis would
say the benefit from them taking the shot, as
you as you alluded to it, does it prevent them
from getting infected or spreading it anyways?
The benefit is minuscule, but as Joe Ladipo and
other studies have shown, there is a risk for
doing it. So why can't our medical establishment
acknowledge that? Why the deception? Why have
they continued to do this for now? Two years?
Speaker 1: I have to tell you, I don't know what
he's talking about in the sense that it seems
widely known. Or is anyone covering up that these
new vaccines don't prevent the spread and they
don't appear to prevent infection? But the idea is
to protect you from a really serious case. I would
love it. Remember, I had COVID last week. I would
love it if the vaccine did protect me completely.
It didn't, but I felt really sick for 28 hours.
It seems plausible and backed by the science
that I had 28 hours of feeling really sick
rather than three days. Five days. Whatever
the case may be on average. Remember with
one person, you can never say because you
either are vaccinated when you get COVID or
you don't. That it was shortened dramatically
and it did not get more serious because of the
vaccine. I mean, it seems to me everybody's
been up front about that since the vaccines with
the new variants stopped preventing infection.
It would be great for it to be better, but
the idea that there's huge wrongdoing here,
it does not seem based on the facts. Now,
why is this and is doing this? The scientists
believes this is an issue he can use to
beat Trump, the MAGA base. Is Anti-Vaxx.
But Trump says, I did a great thing by getting
these vaccines. But it's up to you whether you
get it. But you should. But you shouldn't
have to. And the MAGA base disagrees with
Trump. They often will boo Trump when he talks
about the vaccines. DeSantis correctly perceives
this is a wedge that could be put between
Trump and his base to disband this benefit.
If DeSantis chooses to run. The problem is that
the calculation might work in the primary and not
work in the general. And what I mean by that is
the vast majority of the public supports vaccines
and taking an anti-vaccine position in the primary
that you then can't run away from in the general.
Because at the end of the day, if DeSantis runs
and he goes anti-vaxx in the primary, he'll just
stop doing that when it gets to the general and
pretend it never happened. But it may be difficult
to run away from that position in the general and
that could actually damage Ron DeSantis. This is
all speculative since the Santos hasn't actually
announced that he's running for anything yet,
although every sign seems to be pointing in that
direction. After the break, we will talk about
a new poll as well as why 24 could end up being a
disaster for Trump if DeSantis does choose to run.
That'll be after the break. But in the immediate.
DeSantis going anti-vax. It's a calculated move.
I don't personally believe DeSantis believes any
of this stuff he's saying. I just don't knowing as
much as I know about DeSantis. But he's trying
to use it to set up this wedge to try to drive
MAGA voters away from Trump and potentially
towards him if he decides to run for president.